I've been talking to you for it's like
like 20 years now that I feel like that
I've known you and you always look
pretty much the same you haven't changed
in a way that I find a little bit eerie
that's okay have you have you ever had a
period of your life where you just fell
apart that I didn't know about because
I'm rooting for that to be true no it's
already happened it could happen again
though so what you know stay tuned but
know there was a period I went and shot
a movie with Peter Jackson called King
Kong down a museum yes yes and I really
got into the Hobbit lifestyle when I was
down there a lot of mutton a lot of beer
absolutely zero time at the gym and I
got really tubby you got tubby I got I
got really tubby and in fact when I came
back to the States
I remember my dad said to me one day he
goes hey when you have a moment I'd
really like to talk with you about
something and I got kind of freaked out
because normally he doesn't like preface
a conversation just say what he's
thinking yeah and and busy this is We
Need to Talk
and I instantly got very scarce oke okay
what is it because I want I want to tell
you as an actor I want you to know
Europe you're a little tubby right now
you're a little out of shape and you
might want to think about getting into
shape and and I had sort of come up with
his excuse because I'd taken another job
that was a little bit more dramatic and
I was playing sort of this dark kind of
scary guy and I sort of used as an
excuse to just keep the tubby thing
going a little bit more right and so I
told him I said yeah you know I'm a
little out of shape now but you know
it's really for this character goes
uh-huh is that character ever seen in a
skinny is that character skinny at all
in the movie I said no he goes no one's
gonna care they're just gonna think
you're tubby you should lose the way
right and true to form listen to him no
I didn't yeah I got the tub yarn because
I thought I was making like this brave
artistic choice sure and then true to
form the first review said alone with
her a dark psychological thriller
calling a starring an out-of-shape
colony just said tubby
like it is you gotta listen to your dad
I know
you